foreign
with 1-1 weapons company 81 Splatoon on
Camp Pendleton California
Rock
I joined a few months after September
11th feeling like I think most people in
the country did at the time filled with
a sense of patriotism and retribution
and the desire to do something that
coupled with the fact I wasn't doing
anything I was 17 just graduated from
high school that past summer living in
the back room in my parents house paying
rent in the small town I was raised in
Northern Indiana called Mishawaka I
could spell that later for people who
are interested Mishawaka is many good
things but cultural Hub of the world it
is not so my only exposure to theater
and film was limited to the plays I did
in high school and and Blockbuster video
when she rest in peace I was serious
enough about acting that I auditioned
for Juilliard when I was a senior in
high school
didn't get in determined College wasn't
for me and applied nowhere else which
was a genius move I also did that uh
Hail Mary La acting Odyssey that I
always heard stories about of actors
moving to LA with like seven dollars and
finding work and successful careers I
got as far as Amarillo Texas
before my car broke down I spent all my
money repairing it finally made it to
Santa Monica not even la
stayed for 48 hours wandering the beach
basically got my car drove home thus
ending my acting career so 17 Mishawaka
parents house paying rent selling
vacuums uh telemarketing cutting grass
at the local 4-H Fairgrounds this was my
world going into September 2001. so
after the 11th and feeling an
overwhelming sense of Duty and just
being pissed off in general at myself my
parents the government you know not
having confidence not having a
respectable job my shitty mini fridge
that I just drove to California and back
I joined the Marine Corps and I loved it
I love being a marine it's one of the
things I'm most proud of having done in
my life firing weapons was cool driving
and detonating expensive things was
great but I found I love the Marine
Corps the most for the thing I was
looking for the least when I joined
which was the people these weird dudes
Motley Crew of characters from a
cross-section of the United States that
on the surface I had nothing in common
with and over time
all the political and personal bravado
that led me to the military dissolved
and for me the Marine Corps became
synonymous with my friends and then a
few years into my service and months
away from deploying to Iraq I dislocated
my sternum in a mountain biking accident
and had to be medically separated and
for those who were never in the military
they find this hard to understand but
then being told I wasn't going to deploy
to Iraq or Afghanistan was very
devastating for me
it's very clear image of leaving the
base Hospital on a stretcher on my
entire platoon was waiting outside to
see if I was okay and then suddenly I
was a civilian again
I knew I wanted to give acting another
shot because again this is me I thought
all civilian problems are small compared
to the military I mean what can you
really [__] about now you know it's hot
someone should do it on the air
conditioner you know this coffee line is
too long I I was a marine I knew how to
survive I would go to New York and
become an actor and if things didn't
work out I'd live in Central Park and
dumpster dive behind Panera Bread
so I re-edition for Juilliard and this
time I was lucky enough I got in but I
was surprised by how complex the
transition was from military to civilian
and I was relatively healthy I can't
imagine going through that process
on top of a mental or physical injury
but regardless it was difficult in part
because I was in acting school I
couldn't justify going to voice and
speech class throwing imaginary balls of
energy at the back of the room doing
acting exercises where I gave birth to
myself well my friends were serving
without me overseas
um but also because I didn't know how to
apply the things I learned in the
military to a civilian context I mean
that both practically and emotionally
practically I had to get a job
and I was an infantry Marine where
you're shooting machine guns and firing
mortars there's not a lot of places you
can put those skills in the civilian
world
and emotionally in that I struggled to
find meaning
in the military everything has meaning
everything you do is either steeped in
Tradition or has a practical purpose and
you can't smoke in the field because you
don't want to give away your position
you don't touch your face because you
have to maintain a personal level of
health and hygiene you face this way
when colors plays out of respect are
those people who went Before You You
Walk This Way because of this you talk
this way because your uniform is worn
and maintained to the inch and how
diligently you followed those rules
spoke volumes about the kind of marine
you were your rank said something about
your history and the respect you had
earned and the civilian world there's no
rank
here you're just another body I felt
like I constantly had to prove my worth
all over again and the respect civilians
were giving me while I was in uniform
didn't exist while I was out of it there
didn't seem to be a
a sense of community whereas in the
military I felt this sense of community
how often in the civilian world
are you putting a life or death
situation when you with your closest
friends and they constantly demonstrate
that they're not going to abandon you
and meanwhile in acting school
uh I was really for the first time
discovering playwrights and characters
and plays that had nothing to do with
the military but Were Somehow describing
my military experience in a way that
before to me was indescribable
and I felt myself becoming less
aggressive as I was able to put words to
feelings for the first time and
realizing what a valuable tool that was
and when I was reflecting on my time in
the military I wasn't first thinking on
the stereotypical drills and discipline
and pain of it but rather these small
intimate human moments these moments of
great feeling of friends going hey well
because they missed their families
friends getting divorced grieving
together celebrating together all within
the backdrop of the military and I saw
my friends battling these circumstances
and I watched the anxiety It produced in
them and me not being able to express
our feelings about it
and and the military and theater
communities are actually very similar
you have a group of people trying to
accomplish a mission greater than
themselves it's not about you you have a
role You Have To Know Your Role within
that team every team has a leader or
director sometimes they're smart
sometimes they're not you're forced to
be intimate with with complete strangers
in a short amount of time the
self-discipline the self-maintenance
uh I thought how great would it be to
create a space that combined these two
seemingly dissimilar communities that
brought entertainment to a group of
people that considering their occupation
could handle something a bit more
thought-provoking than the typical
mandatory fun events that I remember
being voluntold to go to in the military
all well intended but slightly offensive
events like win a date with the San
Diego Chargers cheerleader where you
answer questions about pop culture if
you get it right you win a date which
was a chaperone walk around the parade
Deck with this you know already married
pregnant cheerleader and
nothing against cheerleaders I love
cheerleaders the point is more how great
would it be to have theater presented
through characters that were accessible
without being condescending so we
started this non-profit called arts in
the armed forces where where we tried to
do that tried to join these two
seemingly dissimilar communities we we
pick a play or select monologues from
Contemporary American plays that are
diverse in age and race like a military
audiences
grab a group of incredible theater
trained actors arm them with Incredible
material heat production value as
minimal as possible no sets no costumes
no lights just reading it
to throw all the emphasis on the
language
and to show that theater can be created
at any setting it's a powerful thing
getting in a room with complete
strangers
and reminding us ourselves of our
humanity and that self-expression is
just as valuable a tool as a rifle on
your shoulder and for an organization
like the military that Prides itself on
having acronyms for acronyms can get
lost in the sauce when it comes to
explaining a collective experience and I
can think of No Better Community to arm
with a new means of self-expression than
those protecting our country so
we've gone all over the United States
and the world from Walter Reed and
Bethesda Maryland to
Camp Pendleton to Camp Arif John and
Kuwait to USAG Bavaria on and off
Broadway theaters in New York and for
the Performing artists we bring you know
it's a window into a culture that they
otherwise would not have had exposure to
and for the military it's the exact same
and in doing this for the past six years
I'm always reminded that acting as many
things it's a craft it's a political act
it's a business it's
um whatever adjective I guess is most
applicable to you but it's also a
service I didn't get to finish mine so
whenever I get to be of service to this
ultimate service industry the military
for me again there's not many things
better than that
uh thank you
so we're going to be doing a piece from
Marco Ramirez called I am not Batman uh
incredible actor and good friend of mine
Jesse Perez is going to be reading and
Matt Johnson who I just met a couple
hours ago they're kind of doing it
together really for the first time so
we'll see how it goes so Jesse Perez and
Matt Johnson
it's the middle of the night and the sky
is glowing like mad radioactive red and
if you squint you can maybe see the moon
through a thick layer of cigarette smoke
and airplane exhaust that covers the
whole city like a mosquito net that
won't let the Angels in
and if you look up high enough you could
see me standing on the edge of a 87
story building
and up there a place for gargoyles and
broken clock towers that have stayed
still and dead for maybe like a hundred
years up there is me and I'm freaking
Batman
and I got Batmobiles and batarangs and
freaking bat caves like for real and all
it takes is a broom closet or a back
room or a fire escape and Danny's
hand-me-down jeans are gone and my navy
blue polo shirt the one that looks kind
of good on me but has that hole on it
near the butt from when it got snagged
on the chain link fence behind Arturo's
but it isn't even a big deal because I
tucked that part in and it's like all
good
that blue polo shirt it's gone too and I
get like like transformational
and nobody pulls out a belt and whips
Batman for talking back or for not
talking back and nobody calls Batman
simple or stupid or skinny and nobody
fires Batman's brother from the Eastern
taxi company because they was making
cutbacks neither because they got
nothing but respect and not like afraid
respect just like respect respect
because nobody's afraid of you because
Batman doesn't mean nobody no harm
ever
because all Batman really wants to do is
save people and maybe pay abuela's bills
one day and die happy and maybe get like
mad famous for real
oh and killed the Joker
tonight like most nights I'm all alone
and I'm watching and I'm waiting like an
eagle or like a no yeah like an eagle
and my Cape is flapping in the wind
cause it's freaking long and my pointy
ears are on and that mask that covers
like half my face is on too and I got
like bulletproof stuff all in my chest
so no one can hurt me and nobody nobody
is gonna come between Batman and justice
from where I am I could hear everything
somewhere in the city there's an old
lady picking styrofoam leftovers up out
of a trash can and she's putting a piece
of sesame chicken someone spit out into
her own mouth
and somewhere there's a doctor with a
whack haircut and a black lab coat
trying to find a cure for the diseases
that are going to make us all extinct
for real one day
and somewhere there's a man a man in a
janitor's uniform stumbling home drunk
and dizzy after spending half his
paycheck on 40 ounce bottles of twist
off beer and the other half on a
four-hour visit to some lady's house on
the street where the lights have all
been shot out by people who'd rather do
what they do in this city in the dark
and half a block away from janitor man
there's a group of good for nothings who
don't know no better waiting for Gather
a man with rusted bicycle chains and
imitation Louisville Sluggers and if
they don't find a scent on him which
they won't they'll just pound at him
till the muscles in their arms start
burning till there's no more teeth to
crack out but they don't count on me
they don't count on no dark night with
the stomach full of grocery store brand
macaroni and cheese and cut up Vienna
sausages
because they'd rather believe I don't
exist
and from 87 stories up I could hear one
of the good for nothing say give me the
cash real fast like that just give me
the [__] cash and I see janitor man
mumbled something in drunk language and
turn pale and from 87 stories up I could
hear his stomach trying to hurl its way
out of his Dickies so I swooped down
like mad fast and I'm like Darkness I'm
like Swoosh and I'd throw a batarang at
the one naked light bulb
and they're all like whoa [__]
who just turned out the lights
what's that over there what give me what
you got old man did anybody hear that
hear what there ain't nothing no really
there ain't no bat but then
one out of the three good for nothing
gets it to the head bow and number two
swings blind into the dark cape before
him but but before his fist hits
anything I grab a trash can lid in right
in the gut and number one comes back
with the jump kick but I know Judo
karate too so I'm like
twice
but before I can do any more damage
suddenly we all hear a click click
and suddenly everything gets quiet
and the one good for nothing left
standing grips a handgun and aims it
straight up like he's holding Jesus
hostage like he's threatening maybe to
blow a hole in the Moon
and the good for nothing who got it to
the head you try to jump kick me and the
other good for nothing who got it in the
gut it's both scrambling back away from
the dark figure before him
and the drunk man the janitor man is
huddled in a corner praying to Saint
Anthony because that's the only one he
could remember
and there's me
eyes glowing white Cape blowing softly
in the Wind
bulletproof chest heaving my heart
beating right through it in a morse code
for [__] with me just once come on just
try
and the one good for nothing left
standing the one with the handgun yeah
he laughs and he lowers his arm and he
points it at me and gives the moon a
break and he aims it right between my
pointy ears like goal posts and he's
special teams
and gender man is still calling Saint
Anthony but he ain't picking up
and for a second
it seems like
maybe I'm gonna lose
don't kill me man snap risk crack neck
slash skin beats acid
and he's on the floor and I'm standing
over him and I got the gun in my hands
now and I hate guns I hate holding them
because I'm Batman and Asterix Batman
don't like guns because his parents got
ice by guns a long time ago but for just
a second my eyes glow white and I hold
this thing for I could speak to the good
for nothing in a language he maybe
understands
click click and the good for nothing's
become good for disappearing into
whatever toxic waste chemical [__]
[__] they crawled out of
and it's just me and janitor man
and I pick him up and I wipe sweat and
cheap perfume off his forehead and he
begs me not to hurt him and I grab him
tight by his gender man sure call her
and I pull him to my face and he's
taller than me but the cape helps so he
listens when I look him straight in the
eyes and I say two words to him
go home
and he does checking behind his shoulder
every 10 feet and I swoops from building
a building on his way there because I
know where he lives and I watch his
hands tremble as he pulls out his
keychain and opens the door to his
building
and I'm back in bed before he even walks
in through the front door
and I hear him turn on the faucet and
pour himself a glass of warm tap water
and he puts the glass back in the sink
and I hear his footsteps
and they get slower as they get to my
room
and he creaks my door open like mad slow
and he takes a step in which he never
does
and he's staring off into nowhere his
face the color of sidewalks in summer
and I act like I'm just waking up and I
say oh what's up pop
and janitor man says nothing to me
but I see in the dark I see his arms go
limp and his head turns back like
towards me and he lifts it for I could
see his face for I could see his eyes
and his cheeks is dripping but not with
sweat
and he just stands there breathing like
he remembers my eyes glowing white like
he remembers my bulletproof chest
like he remembers he's my pop
and for a long time
I don't say nothing
and he turns around hand on the doorknob
and he ain't looking my way but I hear
him Mumble two words to me
I'm sorry
and I lean over and I open my window
just to crack
if you look up high enough
you could see me
and from where I am
I could hear everything
thank you